so often you get to say good morning
good evening whilst doing talks this is
the third talk my third talk today
so obviously it's the one with the
longest title actually if you look at
the talks that I've done today they
titles have got progressively longer so
good job we don't have a late evening
talk so this is actually is probably the
longest talk title I've ever had and yes
I did actually go to BuzzFeed to just
check the fonts on the colors and go
just to make sure I have that like air
of authenticity what can I say about
myself and two books with long titles
another book with a long title and some
other stuff these books have nothing to
do with me it turns out that in addition
to being interested in patents coding
techniques software craftsmanship and
taking photographs of books I also have
an interest in words and language and I
have a page on Facebook word Friday
where I present various unusual bits and
pieces and acquaintance of interest so
if you language is a thing that you are
interested in and then I recommend this
so given that context I'm going to
explore the word Enterprise from moment
because I've used it in the title and in
fact we use it everywhere these days we
start talking about enterprise scale and
is that ready for the enterprise and a
system system can barely go by without
somebody throwing the word enterprise in
its direction now there is a small
problem well I don't think it is a
problem but if you are of a particular
disposition and possibly even a
particular generation in spite of the
onslaught of the word enterprise in
software development over the last two
decades I still think of this you know
somebody says enterprise enterprise
software and I'm thinking ok yeah
running a starship but warp speed that's
going to take some serious horsepower
and you're going to need some major CPU
work here and I want to know what
languages they use then what's the
runtime there's lots of interesting
things there and yeah it's an elegant
and it's an elegant design
the reboot especially so and indeed it
does turn out that you'll look at if you
look at this drawing there's a NASA logo
lurking in the background somewhere this
is an assets impression of what a warp
drive craft would actually look like and
it is actually based on some real
science the those are warped rings warp
coils and this is based on a theory this
be explored by a NASA by a NASA team
obviously it's in the highly speculative
department Sonny white is exploring
potential applications of what is known
as Alcubierre Drive Miguel Alcubierre a
Mexican physicist who in 1994
demonstrated that general relativity
actually does accommodate the concept of
what we would call warp drive and
without violating that that awkward
speed limit the speed of light you
cannot travel faster than speed than the
speed of light in a vacuum
we can work around that with software
developers we know about work around it
turns out that this is not an obstacle
all you need to do is move space-time
move the vacuum faster than the speed of
light and you're good yeah you will be
traveling in the vacuum at a slower
speed and that's great and basically you
warp space-time that's what those coils
are for they contain exotic matter this
is what we would call a technical
challenge we don't actually know that
that exists estimates vary but it is
entirely possible the amount of exotic
matter you would need to warp space in
this fashion is approximately the mass
of the moon I think that is known as a
implementation detail and we're going to
map it out on our storyboard and just
see how we go why am i introducing this
stuff well one it's the end of the day -
good nerdy fun and three what I want to
talk about is the reality distortion
field that is the enterprise we do warp
space and time and the very substance of
reality on a regular basis so I'm
plundering the dictionaries
we are told that enterprise is a project
or undertaking that is especially bold
complicated or arduous yeah complicated
largest that can't let sir that's a
enterprise polite way of saying all this
is going to be tricky it's going to be a
lot of work readiness to engage in
undertakings of difficulty risk danger
or daring you know it's just that yeah
we've got this budget oh this is going
to be interesting oh you need to deliver
it by then yep okay I dare you a design
of which I love the wording I cannot
remember I'm going to suspect this is
the Oxford English Dictionary given the
phrasing a design of which the execution
is attempted nothing about achievement
nothing about completion we'll just try
it and there's a bunch of other ones
that are really boring so we're not
interested in those so um there's also
least the question of what we mean by
code if I'm talking about Enterprise
coding clearly I need to have a
reasonable definition of code a set of
instructions for a computer I think
we're all reasonably comfortable with
that they compute a program or a portion
thereof yeah likewise now it gets
interesting
a system of words figures or symbols
used to represent others especially for
the purposes of secrecy yes this is
enterprise code now we have a
satisfactory definition also a set of
conventions or principles governing
behavior or activity in a particular
domain there's a concept of a code of
conduct concept of code as a set of
conventions and practices or even a
definition of a culture by which we
participate in our daily activity so
there's also a lot going on here so
let's talk about some of these implied
practices and here is an interview if
you follow the practical dev on Twitter
but these have been doing the rounds
these kind of really these fake O'Reilly
book covers they are they are very funny
in that kind of like there's so much
truth in that it hurts
taking on needless dependencies fragile
developing guard yeah code written by
some stranger on the Internet is always
perfect and we have a beautiful example
of this about ten months ago in fact one
developer just broke no Babel and
thousands of projects in eleven lines
javascript this was a little piece of
code left pad it turns out that lots of
libraries had a transitive dependency on
this little piece of code and for
various reasons the author pulled them
for all npm and lots of websites stopped
working now clearly this little piece of
code is very very important i mean you
know it must be really really important
it must be must be something super
clever because otherwise why would you
be reusing it because that is one of the
reasons people often give this is the
reason we have code reuse we reuse code
because somebody else has done the work
and it is tricky or daring and you know
what we don't want to reinvent the wheel
and really that code has stood the test
of time let's not look at the code
this is JavaScript which I will happily
say is not my favorite language this is
the code and it seems a little bit
clunky it seems a little bit of Rasik
and what's it doing it's um left pad yes
it's actually filling out a string it's
padding the string for this thousands of
websites went down it is padding a
string because it turns out there it
turns out sometimes when I have a casual
discussions with people about the use of
the word developer and versus the word
programmer and I know some actually well
I use the word developer I'm actually a
strong advocate of the word programmer
because I've had people sort of say to
me wow you know programmer just makes it
sound like you're a coder and I said
well I don't think that's really true
I mean developer makes it sound like
you're involved in real estate you know
so you know they both have potential
negatives but the thing is that I have
encountered the deeper truth in all of
this developer there's a lot of
developers you can't program it's a
shameful confession it turns out that
programming is a lot harder than
developing and this is this is one of
the demonstrations so what I found
absolutely fascinating was that NPM went
and put up a version that somebody else
is now maintaining now I would have
presumed that somebody who's maintaining
this piece of code is going to do
something visually clever and really
tidy is up because I mean there's a
unfortunately forced to follow the
rather curious semantics that this thing
has in terms of its defaults but you'd
think they're going to do something
really clever
instead they did this there's a cache up
there that is actually if you look at it
is going to be slower than actually
running the code there's lots of
comments just to help you in case you
can't understand all of this and it is a
and we don't use plus equals because
obviously equals something equals
something plus something is what this is
written by somebody who I think it has
got their heart in the right place but
their brain was out of the room at the
time you know we have a lot of newbie
programmers and it's a shame that this
is now the standard version absol I'd
have a go at it as I say not a Java
program a JavaScript programmer so this
is my version which is shorter it's
direct it even accounts for the
weirdness this also has a very
interesting property it works I had I
know this stuff because I wrote some
test for it so I created this ad hoc
testing framework and a bunch of
assertions is assertions that's the
testing framework and that's what
happens when you run it against my code
these are the expectations you would
have a somebody described less pad to
you if I run it against the versions
they're actually maintained at NPM and
three tests fail so yeah
alternative you could use a real
language like Python which actually has
this kind of built in and that doesn't
have the ambiguity you've got a choice
there between zero filling and write
justifying correctly building two
languages Java Script will have such a
padding function you know I don't think
two decades is too long to wait for such
a thing but there is this issue about
how we relate to code and this kind of
stuff it doesn't just pop up on the
internet what we see is in large
organizations relatively simple
programming tasks are well people bring
a mindset to them and it's not that
people are stupid it turns out
programmers are surprisingly smart it is
just that sometimes when you approach
the problem from the wrong angle you can
really make something of it uses Buzz
earlier so that's that's so let's go
let's go back to first bus what looking
at people solving this problem it's
absolutely fascinating
because we people often think I was
fairly trivial I was when I started
really looking at fizzbuzz I've been
dismissive of it before that's right
four years ago now I started looking at
him gosh you know what there's some fun
to be had here so I thought let us
consult the great sink of all human
knowledge Wikipedia and see what it has
to say on the subject
apparently I discovered at that point is
a group word game for children to teach
them about division that's certainly not
how I learnt it when I was a teenager
and there's a whole description of how
to play it we highlight the things of
interest in account numbers 1 2 3 except
any number divisible by 3 is fear so 1 2
fears for buzz 5 fears and so on 14 is
buzz 16 and then so and the idea there
is that you are doing a substitution and
conditional substitution it's not the
hardest thing in the world but actually
the thing that drew me and this is the
great thing there's these little gems
these little nuggets buried in Wikipedia
just like they're buried in enterprise
comments it is the use of word dense
force I mean perhaps after whoever wrote
that piece that is archaic it is only
occasionally used in poetry it kind of
left mainstream English around the 17th
or 18th century it would be unusual to
find it even in Victorian England so you
know well done that is probably the most
interesting thing about that article
apart from the fact that it then goes on
to say adults may play fizzbuzz as a
drinking game this is where I learnt it
we're making a mistake leads to the
player having to make a drinking related
forfeit and really I'm going to say you
do need to have alcohol to make this
interesting well we tried playing it as
a family we're on holiday about a year
ago and so that's me my wife and the two
boys at the time my young my younger one
was 10 but he really likes his numbers
he's got a good relationship with
mathematics so we decided to play this
while waiting for our food and our wine
which means the adults were shockingly
sober at this point and we can all do
our times tables and I don't know I
think we got about 50 before we gave up
it's just like we are sober and we can
all do this this is dull you need
alcohol to make it interesting
the best bit about the Wikipedia article
though citation needed yeah there's a
lot of people who won't remember that
they had a drinking forfeit every time
they got it wrong but you know there it
is
now there's a deeper reality that what
we find is that it's been used as an
interview question for many programmers
and and we kind of assume that everybody
is able to do this stuff and we have it
will generally tend toward something
like this so here it is in in Python and
there's a kind of a sort of a simple
ways of doing it for example this is the
accumulation model we recognize that
there is a divisible by three a
divisible by five we accumulate into a
result but we check did we get anything
if we didn't we're going to go with a
number alternatively we have a basically
a tail return approach where we check
each case explicitly and there's no RIA
cumulation of state but actually we are
still testing something twice that and
mod fifteen is effectively n mod three
and in more five so we're always
stopping we're either rechecking
something or stopping to recheck
something and it's there's something
here that is quite interesting of course
we can take the fully and so there's
nothing exciting if you just want to
solve it to get something going but if
you're going to do this in a in a truly
scalable solve no more than you need
simplest solution works all this kind of
stuff you may end up with this approach
and you can end up with this if you do
TDD horribly wrong we'll test the one
case now we'll test the two case now
with tests for three case you'll see the
progression you're getting paid by the
line of code well done good job so you
know there are some fairly crazy ways of
doing it
crazier than this still might still my
favorite and it gets embellished and
added to over the years is the fizzbuzz
Enterprise Edition which I did have to
sell somebody know this really is a
spoof fought a spoof site because
somebody was people are not always sure
you know it's just like is this a joke
or is this not because we've had so much
experience of enterprise software but
sometimes you think this is funny but
actually no really
isn't it could actually be real
enterprise software marks a special high
grade class of software you can always
feel the scare quotes coming in a
software that makes careful use of
relevant software architecture design
principles to Bill's particularly
customizable and extensible solutions to
real problems which of course fizzbuzz
it's just crying out for
parameterization configurability you
know sir this project is an example how
the popular fizzbuzz game might well be
built aware it's subject to high quality
standards of enterprise software and
here I'm just going to just I'll just go
to this yeah just look at the the past
name on that and get hub and it's just
right here the some of the factories
because yeah you know that's that's how
you doing real software development
you've got factories that's a you know
and there's above strategy factory
there's a buzz string printer factory
there's a buzz string returner factory I
I was slightly disappointed not see any
factory factories but you know we've got
integer integer string returner
factories which I thought was quite good
and don't have any don't have any loops
because we've got loop component
factories and it's just you know this is
the kind of thing that you could hang up
in in an art gallery
you know it's truly a work of art you
aren't hanging up in an art gallery or
you get a large budget for it so it's at
this point that we can kind of take a
bit of wisdom from Paul Anderson I have
yet to see any problem however
complicated which when you looked at it
in the right way did not become still
more complicated okay this is almost a
manifesto for software development
sometimes you feel that there's a
approach that sometimes people take they
don't know they're doing it and this is
the thing how do you create a large
problem you give people the mindset that
it's going to be big if you tell people
this is going to be six months worth of
work they will pack it full to the six
months and beyond if you give them the
same task in 18 months they will more
than lies for that challenge and overrun
the project okay if you take a ten
people to solve a task I'm pretty sure
that ten people be able to do it but
they will also be able to do you also be
able to do with a hundred people and
what you get out of that hundred people
will be not too similar to this
okay sorry I thought it's sort of a
tangential experience of one that was
actually a ten versus 100 system it was
done in two different parts of the
country and being a true enterprise one
passed one part of the organization
didn't know the other part was producing
identical software and they didn't know
it was a big problem so they had ten
developers work on it in under a year
whereas the other guys clearly thought
that it took a hundred people three
years to do the same thing you know one
of those guys doing ten people you know
delivering early doing have they have no
idea of the complexity they have not
looked at it closely enough so it is
this sort of Anderson approach that we
were able to take we can mess about I
mean there's a lot of funion you feel
you want to throw a lamdaur at it and
you know you can do that you can make it
even shorter in Python this is one of
the shortest that I know of
I've not been able to get it I'm able to
get it to know apart from knocking out
whitespace that's about as short as I've
been able to get it fits in a tweet
which I write which I rather like but it
also there is a case where we can also
become too clever in a different way and
there's a a rather elegant paper that
somebody pointed me in the direction of
last year match your pirogue fizzbuzz in
haskell by embedding a domain-specific
language you know you know when
somebody's going to you know when
somebody uses words like DSL and Haskell
and then they throw it at fizzbuzz that
you're in for some kind of rollercoaster
ride and it's a very interesting paper
it's also worth looking at on SlideShare
it's more gentle in that and as he says
yeah the default action is executed only
if some previous actions were not
executed so if I revisit this one and go
back to this one in JavaScript
there's our kind of accumulation model
we have to revisit stuff I can be a
little bit crazy here and do it as a
kind of sort of table lookup I'm quite
quite proud of the bonkers notion of
that one that is a little bit crazy but
again I have to recheck the or on the
right-hand side basically is a recheck
basically I have to check the results on
the left and then do an action on that
so I haven't really got rid of the
recheck although I've certainly
well there is a there is a saying that
if you kind of dazzle people with
brilliance baffle them with [ __ ] and
this is a kind of a good example because
I you busy looking at the table lookup
going whatever but a little all on the
right-hand side means I have not got rid
of the second check so he comes up with
a sort of says although we asked if we
can accomplish this without having to
check the conditions for the previous
actions twice in other words if we can
make the control flow follow the
information flow without losing
modularity and there's a whole load of
detours and fascinating stuff in the
haskell paper but I really wasn't sure I
could understand it so I gave myself the
challenge I thought I can only I will
understand it if I can implement the
same result or all parts of his working
if I can do that in a number of
different languages so I had to go I
going ban Java and C++ Python and groovy
and here's is a the JavaScript version
and which I are kind of proud off in a
kind of sad way but all nicely landed
and it turns out that this is all based
on function composition and you return a
function you return a higher-order
function that gives you the result you
make the decision about the 3 and the 5
only really once and you return a chain
of functions set of compositions that
will give you the right answer based on
what was given and this is one of those
things that it certainly doesn't have
the vast expanse of the enterprise
fizzbuzz Edition but the density of
ideas in there versus if else you know
you're looking like maybe somebody's
been a little bit too clever here yeah
this is the other kind of enterprise
hanging out in every enterprise it's a
there are smart individuals who are
frustrated by the rather sort of verbose
nature of other code and they are
seeking to distill everything down to I
mean I feel a little bit indulgent that
I've actually used I've actually I've
retained the vowels and the word test
fees and buzz but there we've certainly
got rid of all the other letters those
are not necessary clearly and we've
reduced it to its essence and we can
wander around feeding mathematical
functional and remarkably cool and also
very certain of our jobs so there's this
other side to enterprise programming
that we see in a number of cases at
and again I want to refer to this point
as being asked there's clearly a unique
result of a unique temperament so where
else can we take the stuff well one of
the things that we saw one of the things
that we've seen is is this is concept as
cargo cult programming a style of
computer programming characterized by
the ritual inclusion of code or program
structures that serve no real purpose
and we see a lot of this in their
enterprise programming and it's perhaps
best to think about it from an
engineering point of view
signal-to-noise ratio your code your
source code it has desired signal and it
has noise and we use this informally and
as a metaphor talk about useful
information versus false information or
irrelevant data most common source of
noise well first of all there's the
intelligent expansion of things managed
to get Shakespeare into my other two
Talk's today so it I felt it was
necessary to get into the video final
talk so a reasonably famous soliloquy to
be or not to be that is the question the
author Tom Burton had a go at turning
this into a business speak in his book
long words bother me same content and
yet skillfully double the length with
words which are somewhat longer and you
know continuing existence or cessation
of existence of those are the scenarios
is it more empowering mentally to work
towards an accommodation of the
downsizings and negative outcomes of
adversarial circumstance those of you
would buzz with bingo cards at this
point you're probably doing quite well
okay but as I then pointed out once when
I want to show this I've something that
this is not how a developer would write
it this is not how an enterprise
developer writer they use some kind of
like crazy alignment and you know if you
find most of your code is actually on
the second screen or something like that
and some guy now I know it's fine I've
got 2 HD monitors you know and I'm going
to upgrade to WiMAX soon so I can just
run out to column 500 not a problem and
and so you end up with this kind of
approach now the other one of the other
sources of this not simply paucity in
terms
people's approach you know if I explain
it if I use really long words and I
really spell things out and everything
then it'll be more easily comprehensible
the other one is comments now Rob Pike
wrote this around 1989 actually round
the time that I was learning see I came
across this year and a half later as he
says in these notes on program you see a
delicate matter requiring taste and
judgment I tend to err on the side of
eliminating comments for several reasons
first if the code is clear and uses good
type names and variable names it should
explain itself but I'm going to make a
sort of a cautionary observation here
people often say well you know my code
is you know it's self-explanatory you
know it's a right if you say that that's
that's wonderful but who gets to judge
that and let me just offer you the
suggestion that the self that makes that
judgment is not the self that wrote the
code okay you need somebody else to come
along and go yes my my goodness that is
so clear and crisp it is it does explain
itself beautifully as opposed to have
you been reading that Haskell fizzbuzz
paper again which clearly is a different
different path and second comics aren't
checked by the compiler and I mean the
obvious corollary to that is they also
not check by the programmer
so is that your two audiences and
neither of them is actually interested
and so there's no guarantee they're
right especially after the code is
modified a misleading comment can be
very confusing third the issue of
typography comments clutter code but my
favorite thing about the Rob Pike quote
is is this aspect he he threw in this
little observation you know this is
there's a famously bad comment style I
equals I plus one and you know therefore
add one two I there are worse ways to do
it and then he shows a big banner
comment which is magnificent add one to
I and says don't laugh now wait until
you see it in real life so obviously I
laughed when I first read it five years
later I actually did see that in
production code it was at a bank in the
city they no longer exist I mean I've
just put
those two Khan's I just put those two
things there and your mind has already
made a causal relationship between them
and it wouldn't surprise me if there was
some deeper causal relationship because
some of the code I saw there was
shocking and any was stuff like this we
were never told about adding to though
that was on a few lines later apparently
that wasn't worthy of comment so it does
lead to this interesting challenge a
common fallacies to assume authors of
incomprehensible code will somehow be
able to express themselves loosely and
clearly in comments it's not that it
never happens but if the person that
could not explain their code clearly
using code and you say please explain
what you did in English I'm pretty sure
that well experience suggests that most
of the time they will have the same
problem it is the same thinking process
that goes into it if they understand it
at some level but that's not the same as
being able to express it so this is why
you know don't do this stuff alone you
need that other head it turns out
somebody else will give you the insight
that you probably had but were unable to
articulate and cargo can't programming
the ritual inclusion of code that has no
purpose and there's this really
interesting stuff here so I found this
so this is one of those frustrations I
deal with a number different languages
at different times I and there is a
there is a habit in the Java world of
importing everything explicitly and in
detail if you want to use something from
packaged you import just that thing you
don't use wild cards or anything like
that you know I currently have an
average of 15 to 25 imports in each
source file which is seriously making my
code mixed up and confusing I'll just
point out on Stack Overflow too many
imports spamming my code is the URL and
that is the that is the perfect
description of it is spam it is just
noise is too many imports in your code a
bad thing is there any way around this
Stack Overflow this is this is where
this is actually my older son discovered
Stack Overflow without my help and he's
not really a programmer he was just
doing some code and I'm sitting there
and coming along and I said you need any
help said I'll no dad I did have a
question but I found this site stack
over
it's just like yep all roads lead to
stackoverflow the problem is that not
all the roads are that well cleaned okay
and you know you get all kinds of people
traipsing in and so it's normal in Java
world to have a lot of imports we
haven't said if it's good we haven't
said if it's bad it turns out that a lot
of people you know if lots of people are
doing it you know that's okay not
importing whole packages is good
practice and assertion no there's
nothing to back it up
what else did I find it's a good
practice to import class by class
instead of importing whole packages
again we are asserting this without any
kind of qualification so I mean I'm you
know I'm an inquisitive person I like to
know the reason for things in fact that
has got me into trouble I'm not a
troublemaker normally but that has got
me in trouble in in the past when I
really because I've not understood what
something is supposed to be for well how
can I develop it I mean I really need to
understand what is this practice what
makes us tick what problem are we
actually trying to solve it turns out
those are surprisingly awkward questions
and most people choose not to answer
them so back to Stack Overflow
here's people's explanations enough this
it's not a problem
any IDE will manage imports and show
them to you only when needed hang on
most IDE support code folding where all
the imports are folded down to one line
I rarely even see my imports these days
as the ID manages them and hides them as
well hang on so anyway the IDE puts from
there and then it hides it away because
it will get in the way otherwise any
good IDE such as eclipse pause for a
moment frankly will collapse the imports
in one line and you can expand them when
they needed so they won't clutter your
view
so basically we're saying you don't need
them so the IDE give us and it taketh
away
so I mean I remember reading this and it
was just you know facepalm moment so
let's have a look closely what's really
going on here
ah it's not even March so
what is the matrix
control The Matrix is a
computer-generated dream world built to
keep us under control in order to change
a human being into this that is an IDE
you won't pass the matrix the whole
thing is that ideas can really help us
with a lot of stuff but it turns out
that when I ask people about certain
coding practices why you doing that all
the IDE generated it for me the idea
said this is a good thing the IDE said
it was a bad thing but this is a this is
a good style and I can show you why but
that's not the way the IDE defaults you
do know you can change the default we
don't touch the sacred defaults the
sacred defaults has been brought down to
us from the mountain and it's a case of
originally the purpose of the idea is to
help us get around all these things it's
justice
to extend our reach but what happened is
some crazy through the mirror thing
where we reach in he reaches back to us
so let's go back to the original
question I currently have an answer is
it says excusing ya is too many inputs
in your code a bad thing yes it's noise
it's classic noise if I open up a Java
source file assuming it's the first
thing I see is a huge great typically in
bonuses for many languages the first
thing I see is a huge great copyright
statement which is obviously incredibly
useful and you know exactly what you
wanted to look for the terms and
conditions and all the rest of it so a
practice that I'm pretty sure that John
Jagger told me a few years ago was you
pull the noise at the back if you need
the copyright state when you put it at
the end and you have a little bit at the
beginning that says you know look at the
ends it you don't want to read all that
stuff it's irrelevant it's not the first
thing you want to see yeah is there's a
there's a thing you want to drop people
into the action here is the stuff of
interest oh it's not actually the
copyright comment
it's the import again not interesting so
is there a way around it yes it turns
out back in the mid-90s when Java was
created there is a very simple technique
and Uncle Bob has the same view on this
is that I do
avoid long import lists by using what
oh gods long lists of imports are
daunting to the reader we don't want to
clutter up the tops of our modules with
80 lines of imports but people do and
what happens your your eyes slip off the
screen which is why they add the feature
that you can now fold them away they're
so important that they default to don't
worry about this you don't need to see
this don't look at the don't look at the
imports behind the curtain rather we
want the import to be a concise
statement about which packages we
collaborate with the fine detail about
you're actually using this collection
class and this collection class and this
collection class is not interesting
you're using some utils great let's move
on to the next thing of interest a broad
brushstroke view of your dependencies is
sufficient so I I went out and raided
some open source software I tried to
find stuff that was that was dependent
only on the Java standard libraries and
with fairly core code and just doing
basic tasks and there was much longer
ones but I thought I'd do stuff that was
in a reasonable font size so we see this
is not untypical and it reduces
beautifully to one-line I mean are you
actually that interested in all of that
detail remember that you've actually got
the you've got a source file where you
can actually see the coding this has
surprisingly little values similarly we
can reduce all of this to our right
we're using beans that's unusual
reflection and some usuals great not as
obvious this is the point this is noise
I can't actually really see what's going
on if I cared about the detail while I
can see the detail it's called code
we've got that this is should this
should be a broad brushstroke here are
the dependencies it should not be
fragile that every time I make a slight
shift in my choices collections if I
want to use a tree map instead of a hash
map why is that important here it's not
it has no relevance but we artificially
raising its importance we're creating
noise so what is the original motivating
example I was interested so again I
thought I'd dig through and see what why
why are people people are doing this
partly because of IDE support but what
was the original motivating example what
is the motivating example that makes
people say I need to
physically import to avoid name
collisions and in over fifty percent of
the cases that I found and indeed the
ones that were when when this practice
kind of started the ones that are deal
with name collision the observation in
the AWT which nobody uses and inutile
there is a thing called list it has the
same name and therefore there is
potential for a collision and this is
the motivating example the number of
times has actually happens in production
code is vanishing it might not even fit
in a double okay so it turns out that
this is a solvable problem this is how
you do it and been able to do it for
over two decades in other words this is
a this is a salt puff of smoke that has
led people into this crazy style if I
look at other languages I don't see
people doing the same things people are
not individually exporting absolutely
everything a couple of people have
pointed out that people do that in
Python no they don't they don't do this
to the import structure is different and
there is a very very different set of
cultures and support for that as well
so nobody really does it the way the
Java programs do they're kind of special
in that sense now if we're talking about
cargo cult programming the point is that
where does truth come from this is a
very profound question
we're in January and we're in the post
post truth year and I'm going surely
sure that the posts cancel out but you
know but there is this point how do we
obtain truth or one of the most common
ways that we as people detained truth is
through repetition the more you say it
the more true it is I want to get back
to Morpheus here yeah and we all know
what it says because we've seen it on a
thousand means what if I told you
Morpheus never says what if I told you
in any of the Matrix films
mind blown matrix moment red pill taken
he never says that okay and and likewise
um you know Luke I am your father
turns out Duff never says that either
but these are true because we've
repeated them and this is how coding
guidelines and enterprise cultures are
created by the repetition of an idea or
something somebody heard from someone
else and it just goes around and
suddenly that's how we do things here
becomes a culture so we need to be on
our guard for this so we have this idea
this is creates our cargo style and
programming and sometimes we do this
without understanding this idea a
wonderful one a good one to follow as
well the expert beginner what are people
in operations want for me I'm already
logging at the beginning and end of
every method guess I'll do the middle -
yeah
so there's another aspect cargo cult
programming applying a design pattern or
coding style blindly without
understanding the reasons behind that
principle and this has led to as it were
the over adoption of Factory ok the
factory concept is a really good concept
the idea of the complexity of creation
of an object cannot be handled through a
simple new expression there are reasons
perhaps that it cannot be handled
typically related to lack of knowledge
about the core point at the point of
creation we do not know enough to create
this object but somebody else does that
knowledge exists somewhere in the code
if only we were able to embody that and
encapsulate it let us call that idea
Factory
it's a very powerful concept but and one
of the things I quite like about the
path and style that Alastair Coburn used
to use is when describing a pattern he
would not simply describe the mechanics
and the motivation for it he would also
include an overdose section what happens
when I do this everywhere in other words
this is a really good idea you know I
enjoy a glass of wine what happens when
I have 10 I have actually I can't
actually answer that question because I
can't remember
so the point there is and over does it
what happened this is a good idea it
solves a particular part but what if we
just decide you know this is the finest
hammer I have ever seen it is gold and
is wonderful and all of those things out
there are really looking like nails
let's just do that everybody's going to
get a factory this is brilliant and you
end up you know apartment what happens
with hammers I think it was now at price
that gave me the wonderful observation
that you know when all you have is a
hammer then all the world looks like a
thumb and another guy who maintained
some of our code
tell us less turbo he has his
observation was when it when all you
have is a hammer then everything begins
to look like a screw you so you start
kind of like yeah that screws really not
going in I just need to hit harder so we
have this problem a kind of lack of
understanding now normally when people
talk about patterns one of the first up
is going to be singleton
so I'm going to get that one out of the
way I'm not a big fan of singleton
I actually know it's not bad as a
whiskey that will actually improve your
design okay I'm offering you the
singleton that will work because you're
going to sit there and you're gonna have
a sweet little sip of it and kind of
roll around I kind of like beautiful
burning fire of a single mole that's
just my air and you pause because you
can't drink whisky without pausing and
getting philosophical at some point and
you will reason about the nature of the
universe the concepts of code and ones
and zeros will stream through in a
matrix like fashion and you will go you
know what I won't put that big global
variable in my code today I will I will
do good things from my code you just
chill out and relax map sync from never
appears in your code just in your
stomach okay so that's the good stuff
and I did find that I could actually
spell out Kevin any single - it's
surprising what I keep in my office it
turns out so what are some of the other
practices that we have well I referred
earlier on to ever-expanding screen size
so it turns out that you know there was
a concern number of decades ago and it's
resurfacing about what is the carrying
capacity of this planet in population
explosion and so on and you know we're
hitting the seven and a half billion
people mark this is this is a lot but
the population is exploding but there's
a big problem screen sizes and
resolution is expanding far far faster
and there is a problem here because
people start thinking well there's more
real estate on the screen so what I
shall use is I should use longer names I
should be expressive because you're
supposed to be expressive and what and
what I found is about twenty years ago I
was I spent a lot of time telling
developers you know the great vowel
shortage is over the great vowel
shortage of the 70s 80s and early 90s is
over
you can spell word by including all the
vowels you don't have to abbreviate the
hell out of them it's okay
good times are here these days at a
point I guess the point is the crossover
must have happened around 10 to 15 years
ago because now I go around telling me
much too long you need less you need
less you know we're not running a lira
based economy here it's just like less
you know those names are too long we've
got stuff here so bonkers world two
years ago
beautiful cartoon the world seemed
important importantly the scare quotes
are there object-oriented program we
have the entertainment provider
singleton we have the indoor session
initializer we have the privacy manager
delicate my personal favorite the multi
buck supporter you know it's all there
this is this is how people name stuff
now this naming is not merely labeling
if you get the names right you are
communicating design the programming is
an act of communication it is an act of
Applied thinking if this is how you
think you need help
and it's not the kind of help that we
can offer you here in this conference
and there are professionals who can
probably sort you out okay
this is this is a problem the whole
concept of the object metaphor
originally was that we are able to say
you know you see that thing that looks
like a door well it's a door but what if
that collides with another door use
namespaces or packages or whatever you
know it's you know these things are more
direct the only thing that even remotely
looks like its previous forms of
television remote control and but
everything else has simpler name use it
referring once again to Morpheus there
is a point in the matrix where he says
Taniya and by the way if you haven't
watched the matrix you really really
need help you're a software developer
okay come on there's a kind of standard
syllabus of things you need to know that
is in there so I make these references
without apology and there is a point in
the film where you give me as cart come
on stop trying to hit me and hit me and
you look at a lot of names like this it
stopped trying to communicate and just
communicate you're trying way too hard
you're spelling out everything about
this yeah and its mother and it's its
parentage and it's family
och no you don't need that so one of the
things that I do apart from taking
photographs of books and things is I do
actually write a little I don't just
write technical stuff I write short
fiction occasionally for rid of fun and
and so I've got a few books on guidance
for writing and this particular book
comes with the set of cards namely
Apple's observation deck that I thought
it's quite good because it's going
through this a sh t hoff these are
actually applicable to code and I have
picked three here eliminate words name
choose the right name okay these are the
name is not merely a label on your
design your name is your design you
don't have much bandwidth when you're
talking or communicating to somebody
through code if you think about it when
you communicate through codes you only
really got three tools you've got names
you've got spacing you've got
punctuation and there's only so much you
can do with spacing but it helps and
there's only so much you can do with
punctuation because clearly the compiler
has an opinion about where you can and
can't put it it's not like arguments
over should we or shouldn't we use
Oxford commas the compiler has very
definite opinions about know that
semicolon doesn't belong there you
wanted that semi core down here it has
very strong opinions but that's it names
spacing punctuation names of where you
have the greatest freedom that is where
the greatest communication comes from
and so often we squander them because we
think about them as merely labels you
know I will just point out that my two
boys are not called son one son - or
even sing one thing - in reference to
dr. Seuss we did actually spend a lot of
time coming up with names so you know
treat your code in this sense if you're
trying to do something is going to going
to have some endurance and communication
and get specific okay there's a feel
free to get specific so this are
throwing a piece of code that's quite
common one I didn't just see an a piece
of code now we've got an object it's
probably a single tooth configuration
manager
that word manager I'm not going to say
it's always bad but I'm going to say
that it's pretty good probability that
it is bad you know if we were rolling a
six-sided die and you know I said that
yeah use of the word manager comes up on
one that might be about the right ratio
that might even be too generous we might
even have to go to a d20 configuration
manager what is this what does it
represent and so I had this conversation
with one group and so what is it oh it's
the configuration you mean can you can
do that yes it turns out this is the
configuration that's what that's its job
it represents if it doesn't manage it it
don't you know stop trying to hit me and
hit me it is not merely a kind of an
indirection to a thing about a thought
about an abstraction about an idea that
maybe possibly we have something to do
with configuration but we can't say so
directly because that we call no that's
too close say yeah you know it's
configuration there it is this is in a
piece of code for my clients condition
checker for hierarchy of condition
checkers check condition there's a bunch
of noise words get set check validate
there's a whole load of words they they
hang around together you know like the
hanging around together they're the kids
behind the bike sheds just okay yeah
yeah we're going to make plans we're
going to take over the school we get
validations here check get set we're
going to take over we're going to get
everywhere and they do and this is
object-oriented assembler okay we're
using these very very simple overly
primitive kind of knuckle scraping of
naming approaches so I have a
conversation with them because sometimes
you don't it's not obvious what the idea
is it normally comes out and in the
space between people
you throw a conversation it so what do
these do and they told me about the
things in the hierarchy and they were
firing events based on certain
conditions becoming true oh you mean
this yes they said they are conditions
condition checker did we add anything by
adding the word checker except a few
extra letters check condition well what
the conditions do I mean you know let's
let's have a really deep meaningful
consider discussion about the nature of
conditions they can be true or false
oh well there then we're done and then
if you're using the right language you
suddenly realize oh this disappears in a
puff of land Ernest I don't actually
need something there at all because it's
just stuff that I can pass around I
don't need a class hierarchy my
conditions that have to be in that form
so it just disappears and this
progression this procession as it were
of disappearance is quite an important
idea refactoring we often talk about
refactoring as shuffling around code and
the one of the most common refactorings
people deal with is rename okay that is
leaving something in place but
transforming its ability to communicate
and there's there's a fluidity to that
but that's what you want you you don't
know what you're going to say until you
say it in fact sometimes you don't know
what you mean until sometime after the
fact that's what I meant
so names should be considered to be as
fluid as possible okay be a little bit
reluctant about putting things in
published interfaces until you've let
them settle in your mind now I truly
understand the nature of this thing okay
well I'm happy with that okay
listen to your conversations when you're
having them with people see what words
they use in that you use it's just that
you know that abstraction is not the
that's not the right name for it now I
understand that it started over here and
I've retained the same name and people
people give you feedback that was honest
in your head you you have all kinds of
substitutions that you quite happily
apply without realizing most extreme
example I know of was a an example a
number of years ago where I struggled to
understand the purpose of the class that
was named database I've been looking at
the documentation I didn't have the code
I've been on the train been looking at
the documentation and I've been called
in to kind of a chat with somebody about
the problems they were having with the
code from the project manager called me
in and I'm just looking at the
documentation and this is a beautiful
example of the documentation was written
by the person that wrote the code and it
turns out that they weren't very good at
communicating and the code had the same
problem and so I said you know I've been
puzzling all the way from Bristol to
London on the train why is database the
most important class in the system it
seems to be the anchor for everything
and the guy says are no no that's
actually not the database that's the
application controller obviously with a
name like database you would immediately
think that is the application controller
no all the database stuff is in the
classical database to add a database
also database the son of so names matter
they really do you know you don't want
to be sent off in the wrong direction
it's never too late to stop going down
the wrong road so there is a simple idea
a refactoring is a change made to the
internal structure of the software but
it's not just about names it is about
moving things around but one of those
common approaches that I think is
overlooked is the nature of reduction
reducing things down refraction can lead
to additions they can need to move they
can really lay relabeling but
elimination is one of the most important
things this vital act so I'm going to
close with a sort of a brief exploration
of a number of here's that here's a few
smells that I kind of see and they're
kind of interesting because this is
actually based on some code from a from
a client and and I've been dealing with
them for a number of years and so I
could actually run off a number of
things that they enjoyed doing that I've
also seen other people they loved
singleton configuration in fact quite
frankly they have a a deep and quite
frankly unhealthy relationship with
single things overall they're good on
the verbose naming they're also good
going to the other extreme you know
you'll find something that is verbosity
named and then ten lines later
it's they've ripped out the valve and
it's just like how did we go from that
to this this is the bit where I need
more and this is the bit where I can't
don't understand you you've got what I
would refer to as homeopathic naming it
has been diluted below any reasonable
level of potency it has no force
whatsoever but it has a certain belief
system around it
noisy logging what is it about logging
there is a logging one of the most
fascinating things you can ever do in a
project is ask somebody what are you
logging do you
have requirements for your logging have
you as a team discussed what is it that
your logging people get a little bit
uncomfortable with that question because
it's like oh we discussed the customer
requirements and the logging was just
left to the developers so what is it
that you're logging oh we we were told
we should log everything oh you see I
love it when people say that so you log
the act of logging well no that would be
silly well okay
you know call me a little bit you know
pedantic but I have a very clear idea in
my head of that what the word everything
means and clearly you are not logging
everything are you or are you logging
that assignment there no no we don't log
that sir well clearly you are doing a
subset of everything because everything
means everything and then you're not
logging everything so there is a subset
what is it that defines that subset and
then they were so a lot of stuff that
will be useful and then to give me an
example and then somebody else will say
oh I don't log for that I log for this
oh you have personal different
definitions of everything
great so you end up with this one
codebase I saw as three years ago they
had three different approaches to
logging cohabiting in the same codebase
if somebody asked you what does this
code base do just a quick cursory look
at the code i'll just code base logs it
actually controls machinery but first
blush it logs that's what it does most
off if you looked at the proportion of
the lines of code two things that
actually did stuff logging is the most
important single most important activity
in that code base and why were there
three because these three different
factions could not agree with each other
and nobody called in the United Nations
to resolve it log and throw also popular
when it comes to logging log it
repetition and duplication because
that's where truth comes from okay it
must be true I repeated it
but also there's a there's a comfort you
don't even see that you're duplicating
stuff and that is a problem because we
often talk about dry principle but the
things you don't notice it when you
become comfortable with something it
disappears when it no it's either
automated by the IDE or it becomes
automated through this and it bypasses
this bit
yeah and I want you to think about your
breathing for a moment okay you don't
normally think about it do you
that's because it's automatic it turns
out the code duplication is down there
with breathing heartbeat and a few other
fundamental things in a developer it is
not coded into your basic reptile brain
it's automatic your autonomic system
handles it perfectly unnecessary code
source of noise you know either it's for
those or it's just like leftover code
mixed levels of distraction business
concept business concept bit bash bit
bash socket connections per sub point
business concepts you're taken on a
rollercoaster ride which is absolutely
brilliant if you're having a boring day
then going to one of those methods is
quite exciting yeah you'll be awake
pretty quickly it's like whoa hang on we
were doing high-level stuff related to
governance and suddenly on bit shifting
here why am i doing that yeah you can't
fall asleep in that code because the
code will get you
legacy coding habits any language has
been around for more than about two
minutes has legacy code I mean in the
Java exaggerated but obviously there are
different standards you know today I've
been talking a lot about C++ and there's
a whole load of C++ 98 code out there
that never really was good C++ 98 and
now he's having to catch up with C++ 11
and so on visited a company two years
ago they had Fortran that actually goes
back these guys take the record you can
think about how old is the oldest piece
of code that is existed in a company
that you have worked in these guys will
beat it these guys actually had Fortran
code going back to 1959 Fortran was
invented in 1957 they get the record I
have never met a company that has that
kind of like and they are now
programming in the 21st century version
of Fortran that means they have a legacy
spread over half a century you can start
in one part of the codebase and time
travel let us put it this way those
coding idioms have not remained stable
for half a century or so so you end up
and you know in the JavaScript world you
can get legacy coding habits within like
about three or four days because you
know a different framework it's not this
week spring when I was last week's
framework and that's so
programming by coincidence it works and
you look at it and go does that yes it
does it's always worked what works on my
machine and programming right
superstition if somebody once told me
the number we've always followed that
ever since so I'm going to pick on this
code it is what I was fascinated by as a
sort of thinking exercise and I'm not
asking you to read the detail of the
code was that I was able to I was trying
to give an example these guys about
something I basically adopted the style
I said I when you ask some of your write
code badly they can't do it but if you
give them a system and this is the most
important thing I want to get across
here is people are not soft developers
in our it's stupid or malicious by and
large though they they what they do is
they follow codes they follow
conventions they don't even know they
pick them up and what happens is that
what we often consider to be bad code is
a product that is systematic it is not
coincidental or random actually it turns
out that if you say we're going to do
log and throw write that function as if
you were doing log and throw you will be
able to write that function if I give
you a drop down menu of here I like
these style choices so I basically took
a number of these style choices and took
a simple problem and then coded it in
their style and I was or rather I coded
it using those and I'm surprised at how
close it came to their style so it was a
revelation to me it's like yeah what we
often think of as poor code is
systematically created it is not created
arbitrarily or with malice so um what do
we got here we've got a bunch of C++
code I don't need you to know the C++
code I'll talk you through the the bits
that you don't have to worry about we've
got a function called create server
connection the name create server
connection tells you kind of what's
going on so create some connection we've
got a bunch of declarations all the way
up at the top of the function then we've
got a whole load of stuff we're going to
get an address and check its ok and get
it some configuration manager single
turn and then we're going to check
whether the string is empty if it's
empty then oh no we've got a
configuration value missing log and
throw we can do the same again for other
aspects of the address and other bits of
configuration and so we're going to
convert things and then we're going to
create a new object because we want to
create connection
well I mean that's the nature of life
really ultimately isn't it we want would
create connection but here this
particular piece of code that's what
we're going to do and then finally we're
going to tell people that that's what
we're going to return just to make sure
and we're going to do that right so
first of all let's go look at these
these comments whenever you have
comments there are a number of things
that they suggest one of those common
guidelines is that if you comment off
blocks then perhaps those blocks are
named blocks you know we have a name
from named blocks functions
okay so perhaps you should be organizing
like that but I'm not going to get rid
of them just yet and in fact I'm not
going to do that refactoring the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
correct all those damn spelling and
punctuation errors right now I've
corrected it now I delete them okay okay
but there you got it you you gonna you
know this is do the right thing before
you do the right thing okay so that's
gone right there history now the next
thing we may notice is that all of those
declarations are looking at the top and
this is a habit that funnily enough I
mentioned Fortran started out with
fortunately people love to there's some
kind of up with gravitational force the
sovereign function or maybe maybe it's
just smoke smoke rises so maybe maybe
that's what happens but people feel
compelled to put declarations at the top
even when the languages don't require it
so we will distribute this and so that
we can say well look really you should
only be initializing things you should
only be declaring them when you can
initialize there are going to take a bit
of advantage there's a bit of a bit of
extra type information there I can
actually reduce the amount of type
information and use deduced types if
you're familiar it's also in in C++ of
you familiar with c-sharp that's far and
so on so I'm just going to let compiler
do some of the work we both know what's
really going on there's no secrets
between us
so I'm good with this now wait let's
let's go and peel off a couple of bits
here there's some fascinating stuff
going on here not least of which is
these log and throw things
so there's sprinter sprinter F is like
I'm working and see if I start
working in C++ now I'm working in C
sprint F is all really good at things
like allowing buffer overrun attacks
it's that's a great feature built into
the standard library and we also have
another element here which is a curious
piece of legacy coding is that we create
a new object what if new fails if new
fails somebody's going to check that
it's not a null pointer no no it doesn't
return a null pointer it throws an
exception so this first part is a fancy
way of writing true so we'll get rid of
that but the other thing that people
like is they will notice if they are C++
programmers I got all your using raw
pointers you should use some smart
pointers so they'll go ahead and do a
C++ 98 Auto pointer their colleague
would come along correctly with C++ 11
say oh no you should be using unique
pointer I'm going to come along and say
I love your thinking but let's just pull
back a moment because I don't want to
change the interface yes I want to
change the internal structure I'm gonna
use I'm going to use a unique pointer
internally but I don't know changing
outward appearance of the function just
yeah let's sort out the insides before I
start propagating signature changes so
I'm going to take a sort of a rain check
on that one so the next thing we are
going to do is going to have a look at
these these are these various print X
which are there for logging and the
first thing I notice is that there is a
string object and we are asking for its
data that seems a little bit suspicious
the data is the raw data that is the
underlying data of the string I don't
know if what we want what we want in
this particular case is we're passing it
to C style functions we want a C style
string a C star string ends with a null
null terminated you're not guaranteed
that a success the string will have this
by coincidence data will not that the
buffer held will normally have a null
termination it's just easier to
implement it that way so this works by
coincidence so let's do the right thing
and change it to I want to see string
please let's actually capture the
intention but if we look more closely we
realize it in a number of these cases
this is actually not going to be
particularly helpful but in that case
there we can actually instead of using
8y we clearly love the C for the C
library here we can actually do this in
C++ and use f2i which does a proper
string conversion the next thing is to
go and look at the rest of these things
all these others printf notice the
buffer I have no idea how big the buffer
should be 512 make it bigger
that should avoid overruns now people
take a love you know they pick at an
arbitrary number and it's morally a
power of two so it's not completely
arbitrary but if your colleagues ever
pick a number that's not a power of two
you know they are freaks and should be
exported from the building immediately
so I'm you know but nonetheless there's
a piece of hard coding there and let's
get the nature of these things some of
you may go along and say well look but
really you should be using sprint f you
should be using SM printf which does the
buffer checking for you in conditions of
a buffer overrun it's way beyond your
control
10:24 is not going to help you okay so
the next thing let's kind of move in on
these guys and say well really you
should probably be using string streams
and so let's go and use string strings
that's the kind of like the politically
correct C++ 98 answer but if you start
looking at the nature of the strings the
first thing that springs up mind is that
wait a minute that first one is actually
two string literals people don't
intentionally do this in other words
it's actually a fixed string it turns
out the other one you can just do by
adding two strings together you don't
need all this choreography the problem
is when people start down repeating it I
set up a string buffer I put this I put
that they stop their habit prevents them
from seeing that the actual content of
the message can already be dealt with by
the features of the string the next
thing is to go and look at these other
these other ones that don't submit to
quite that simplicity but we've seen we
can add everything together the next
thing I'm going to deal with is this
whole log and throw now sometimes people
may say well hey why don't we need we
need to really rethink to this and
figure this one out I'm actually going
to do a minor simplification here I'm
going to take that one way to tidy
things up is to pull all the stuff you
don't like and put it into one bucket
and say I'll come back to it so I'm
going to factor out log and throw I'm
going to make it
a function failed to connect okay it's
got a little more intention there and
inside that it does log and throw in
other words I haven't sold the log and
throw problem but I've just parceled it
away it brushed it under the carpet
we're going to come back to that carpet
in a bit and in fact now we look at it
you know what I could get rid of those
extra curly brackets there and I know
that this are now I'm now actually
touching a deep point of religion with
many people and you know we all have
different faiths and there you go I'm
doing it it's the end of the day you can
run screaming from the building
afterwards if you like but I like the
idea it was an idea that Uncle Bob put
forward a while back you sort of said
well actually why we why do we always
put these double why we've put these
mashed pans in why we always put the
curly braces and even when it's only a
single statement because we are afraid
of what will happen in certain cases
well it says that compiler is mostly on
your side with this one and all the
other tools are as well but I like the
other way of looking at you said well I
want to create it so that I don't need
them in other words that everything
should be as short as a single statement
ideally and that gets you thinking about
your code very differently so we'll take
that now the next thing to look at is
our friend the less resizes next thing
to look at is our friend the
configuration manager and indeed the
name of the function and its signature
I'm ready for the signature change so
we're going to make that change to the
smart pointer at this point so we're
going to do that we're also going to
change the name because create server
connection well whilst that at one level
isn't it's an accurate description is
that really my intention is it my
intention to create a serve connection
or is it my intention to connect a
server the point is that we know we're
going to create that try and capture
what somebody really wants okay the
problem is there is a developer
sometimes you don't it's very difficult
to zoom out and go that is what we're
trying to achieve are we are trying to
achieve the creation of an object or we
are we trying to have a connection and
that is what we're after next thing
that's going to look at this this
singleton get value not a big fan of get
I would prefer to say that what I'm
after is the value of the address or
simple renaming there we did the other
one earlier on
configuration manager becomes
configuration it's at this point that
you have a moment of insight and you
think wait a minute why are we having
this conversation with this big global
object why don't we just pass in the
configuration the address and the port
as arguments well there you go that's a
lot easier and then if we're passing
them in as arguments why don't we pass
them in as the right types because the
only reason they were coming in as
strings is because we got mad the config
which defaults to representing
everything as a string yeah it's a
string lis type system so the idea is
that by the time we get to this code I
shouldn't have to do any kind of tight
laundering or conversion the goal of
this piece of code is to connect to
server' is not to check whether or not
the configuration is correct it is not
to do transformations on you gave me a
number but you gave it to me in the
wrong type so now I've got to convert it
so well that's a bit easier okay so now
we've reduced this down we can actually
start asking deep philosophical
questions about the nature of creation
and connection and I'm going to say that
the purpose of a constructor which is
being invoked inside the make unique
helper the purpose of a constructor is
not merely to initialize an object it is
to create an object in a well-defined
state therefore we should never be in a
position ideally where we go back to an
object as are you okay you good it was
that good for you you know you know what
worked for you what didn't um we
shouldn't be in that position if that
object could not be created we do not
have a valid connection therefore there
should be no object for a stole on to
the constructor should throw an
exception now is why constructors were
originally invented so therefore there
is no we're going to we're going to get
rid of that and suddenly whoa we got rid
of all that log and throw stuff it's no
longer our problem whoever called us is
going to get all of that somebody else
is going to do work there's a
configuration problem it should be found
earlier this is this is the wrong kind
of late binding if there is a failed
connection we will give them enough
information in the connection
constructor for them to make a decision
as to what they do next at this point
however we realize that there is a
surprisingly little value in this name
and so this is the final refractory
thank you very much
[Applause]